THE LAST FIVE GAMES FOR BOSTON,
THEY HAVE AN THE BRUINS
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE THEY GET THE
FIRST GOAL OF THE GAME.
I THINK BECAUSE THE KINGS.
MOVING  N, BUT IT
IS WAVED OFF. CASE, YOU
CAN COME UP WITH A GOAL THAT
WOULD STAND AND NAL HOCKEY
LEAGUE THE KING'S THIRD MOST. A
WORTH.
HE IN.
>> THIS ONE DOESN'T GO TO THE
GOALTENDER.
IN THAT SITUATION, THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE TAKEN
CONNECTSIS UPRIGHT HE MAKES A P
MARCHAND DOESN'T GET A LOT ON
THAT PER JONATHAN IS DOWN LOW.
TO MAKE THTH, IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT.
DOWN LOW THIS WILL GIVE YOU A
BETTER CHANCE.
THEY WILL FIND A WAY IT FIRST-R
IMPROVES THE ODDS FOR IT.
>> IAFALLO, .
IT IS FOR DYSPRAXIA ROPE BOSTO
THE E
OFF-THE-WALL.
TO THE POINT AND TURNS IT OVER.
IT'S THE BREAKAWAY.
CAMPED OUT IN FRONT OF THE NET
WATCH HIM THEM, THAT
TO THE BACK DOOR.
>> FORTUNATELYE SAME TIME.
YOU CAN SEE THE ENTRY.
AT THE END HABITS WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.